Phillip brace yourself I'm about to say
something controversial what is it the
earth is flat tomatoes aren't really a
fruit the Star Wars prequels were better
than the originals renting isn't always
a bad financial decision say what
but isn't renting just throwing money
away when you buy a home your monthly
payments are going towards something you
will eventually oh yes but not for a
long time thanks to amortization the
first five to ten years of mortgage
payments are mostly interest but but the
home is appreciating right so even if
you're not paying on the principle
you're still making money right true but
not much more than inflation home
ownership might work out for some but
can become a financial burden for others
so when is renting a good financial
decision and is renting viable as a long
term strategy
[Music]
this is Kira she just landed a job in a
new city and has already started
shopping for places to live
she's trying to decide if she should
take the money she saved up and put it
towards house or invest it in index
funds while she rents a great way to
find out whether you should rent or buy
is to look at the price to rent ratio
find two similar houses apartments or
condos in your area one for sale and one
for rent
divide the sale price of one by the
annual rental cost of the other
experts say if the PR ratio is over 15
it's probably less expensive to rent for
example the PR ratio of the city of
Cincinnati is about 8.3 according to the
US Census Bureau in our home town of
Austin it's twenty two point nine and in
San Francisco it's fifty point one put
another way a six hundred thousand
dollar home in San Francisco would rent
for only one thousand dollars a month
there are even free rent versus buy
calculators online that will help you do
the math with your own specifics after
shopping around Kira finds an area that
she's happy with the average home price
is two hundred and seventy thousand
dollars and the average rent is eleven
hundred a month that means her areas PR
ratio is twenty point five and she'll
get more bang for her buck by renting
she also doesn't know if she wants to
live in this city long term making
renting an even more attractive option
she decides against buying home and will
invest the money she saved her a down
payment an index fund instead
when it comes to affording a place to
live Millennials have an uphill battle
baby boomers spent an average of 36
percent of their income on rent
Gen X spent 41% and Millennials now pay
over 45% of their pre-tax income on
housing costs alone this makes it
especially hard to invest save and give
to charity experts suggest keeping your
total housing costs below 30 percent of
your income Kira's new salary is 58
grand here that would mean her maximum
fixed housing expense should ideally
fall below 1450 a month since utilities
are usually 20% of housing expense this
would equate to 1116 a month in rent and
290 for utilities and now she has a
budget to start shopping for a new place
here is new job is downtown but rents in
that area are pretty high further out of
town costs are lower but then there's
the commute one study found that every
mile she has to drive to work cost seven
hundred ninety five dollars a year
through depreciation gas maintenance and
lost wages for Kiera a ten mile commute
might cost her eight thousand dollars a
year she makes a mental note to add
public transit and carpool meetups to
her list of search criteria one often
overlooked resource for renters in a new
city is to work with a licensed realtor
that's right they're not just for
homebuyers a good realtor will know the
best areas to begin your search
they might know about better deals that
aren't widely advertised and best of all
their commission is paid by the property
owner not you hero would be smart to
engage with one to help narrow our
search
Kiera's starting to get a little
frustrated because none of the areas of
town she likes fall within her budget
she's momentarily tempted to throw her
budget out the window when a thought
occurs to her maybe she can keep her
housing costs in line and live in a
great area if she will consider living
with a roommate
thirty percent of working-age adults
live in a so-called doubled up household
she could rent out a spare room to
offset the higher costs and if she wants
to cut costs even more she might look at
home share networks for example senior
home share or Golden Girls Network pair
younger renters with aging homeowners
rent is highly reduced in exchange for a
little help around the house more rides
to a doctor's appointment another common
pitfall renters face is failing to
closely read their lease terms a lease
is a legally enforceable document and
it's your job to arm yourself with the
knowledge of exactly what it says for
example if you move out early and don't
abide by the lease breaking rules
perfectly you could be liable for the
rent of the entirety of the lease and if
you plan to sublet or rent out the
apartment terms will be covered here too
some people are surprised to find out
that damage of their belongings is not
generally covered by their property
owners but renter's insurance is
designed to protect against just that in
the event of water damage fire smoke or
even theft she can rest easy knowing her
belongings are safe the best part
renters insurance is quite cheap for the
price of a pizza cura can know that her
possessions will be fine even if her
building is not Kiera is relieved to
have found a place at last and because
she has that index fund she knows she'll
keep pace with her homeowner friends
renting may be the right choice for
Kiera but it's not for everyone if
you're not strategic about it it can
feel like throwing money away but if
you're careful to keep housing costs low
and invest the money you save it can be
a viable long-term alternative to own
and and that's our two cents
what's the PR ratio in your neighborhood
calculate it and share with us in the
comments
you